[Music]
what a.i thinks felix looked like
without a beard
oh my god i gotta see this i'm scared
oh don't do it man
don't do don't process the [ __ ]
i look handsome look at that jawline
look at that
they did me dirty man look at
it's like they took my entire neck and
just flew now it's weird looking at me
like what is it who am i stop it
stop it oh i have a sword and i
installed the katana chair by the way
if i see a meme i don't like
it's already been cut in half
[Music]
it's from the cocoa video we saved it
so sick look at this huh
that's cool that's what you see before
you die
anyway our boy case i finally follow
felix footstep
i heard about this case i quit twitter
based ksi
twitter used to be an amazing place
where you could connect with people in
different communities and communicate
without any problems yeah
yeah that's why i like twitter now it's
full of potential people
that are ready to cancel and destroy
your legacy for breathing incorrectly
and on that note i'm out let's go
yeah bass ksi lord ksi
hell yeah i swear every youtuber i talk
about twitter they all hate it
but it's like well i used to talk to
people so yeah i'm dealing with it
go back to tumblr please can everyone
else
leave instead felix says we can rename
lawyer me and intellectual
here we go the announcement it's fridays
with pewdiepie
[Music]
i asked you guys last week to come up
with a new name and i don't know i'm not
surprised in the slightest
here we go now we just need day by day
to do the intro
please my dad at my age me
seems about accurate a lot good and
never shave n remember to never shave
captain every time i grow a beard i'm
like this time
this time it's going to be good this
time there's not going to be this weird
gap thing or whatever
this time my my hormone my testosterone
increase epically
it never does random street dog after i
gave him a piece of bread
my lord my cat after i took care of her
for years i belonged to
no one no one cats are so ungrateful man
what's wrong with you huh say thanks
huh thanks for this video say thanks by
smashing my
smashing i like how that's the only way
to refer to a like now you can't just
say hey can you just
like hit the i guess people say hit the
like button never mind
annihilate the like button shatter the
break
that's not what it's wrong i haven't
slept much
shatter shatter the like button crowd
puller
crowd pull pull a crowd puller on that
put a wow on that
put it well when that smile is like but
i can't speak
my brain incompetent super hey great
success
great success like button please
and crush that subscribe button 35 year
old moms
when they see minion memes on facebook
i don't watch minion memes
i'm always ready you know i feel like
this should be in theory this should be
really lame
but it's very cool like you look at the
chair with it
and it's like damn this guy don't [ __ ]
around
i never felt more powerful oh i made a
viking x build
for me oh okay because i like the nether
sword that's sick
looks very cool what did you use here
oh that's cool mixing different textures
looks sick i kind of wanted to build
something above my base like a blood
moon or something like that
i could use this kind of pattern it
looks good
first seen footage of philly shot in
pewdiepie playing together
they finally collapsed that's right i
only collab with
felix sheldberg from now on can't trust
anyone else
everyone else out here getting cancelled
what am i what am i gonna do
so yeah i have my beacons in the middle
right i thought it could be cool time
like a
something there i think that looks sick
i haven't figured out
what yet blood the moon of epic
minecraft destruction i need to stop
playing minecraft this is getting
pathetic
i couldn't afford a pewdiepie chair so i
made my own that's epic man
hell yeah did they change the clutch
i mean you're not getting that italian
leather obviously
but i mean it looks way better big
peepee right there
love it perfect couple doesn't exist now
that's
funny
[Music]
meme oh well done guys
you knocked it out of the park this week
all right so what else do we got i can't
wait now
nice try mom and dad all right the
cheesecake of doom
if you ever get into lawyer again you
get nothing
me gets into the white two more times
and gets nothing
hey three he dies
that bastard told me the truth [ __ ]
actual good suggestion for new name for
y
hilarious cheers gamers never change
well
at least we settled on fridays with
pewdiepie i saw a lot of these like simp
i'm like really
but uh friday's with pewdiepie
how's it going bros and welcome
huge frick lawyer let's rename this guys
me who bought all the hawaii merch no
the stock only
the value on these lives is going to go
way up
anyone that invested in the the wire
merch i mean you're rich now
congratulations
all right here's another suggestion that
didn't make it swedish intellectual
measures peepee sam
cut in half i cut the peepee in half now
i don't vote the
memes anymore i cut the peepee in half
the last guy i collaborated with
quit youtube ken after finding out he
quit i thought it was clear that i was
mimi carson but okay sure
how do they live millionaires versus
billionaires how do they
live i'm on maximum render distance and
i still can't find who the [ __ ] ass
how they live how they live how
how you ever meet the billionaire how
lib
don't get it i wanna nokia but society
won't let me just buy one
jesus christ 79 of people don't know the
opposite word for the following
always never this is a rickroll
i'm cutting your peepee
got em march 23rd 2021
the death of felix shelberg famed
internet celebrity and youtube star
felix pewdiepie has died following
a tragic car
i died
hey guys it's me felix shelburg
now wait who died i don't know the other
guy hey i'm here i'm back what's up
what'd i miss any good memes this week
before i'd block
hot females in my area after adblock
where they go
where all the hot girls in my area just
disappear
just because i installed adblock
remember him this is him now
feel old yet but yeah it's even better
now
i gotta show you guys it's insane it's
crazy
trust me guys pew post every week review
that's that wasn't bad i'll give that a
thumbs up that wasn't bad
my crazy obsessions i love tambourines i
cannot have enough of them
the face of guilt
oh no set in this coming for us
guys we already lost all right when are
we gonna accept this
how do i get more people to subscribe
use your mom's account i don't know what
to tell you
please i need help i watched felix for
seven years got married
and husband joined me and watching for
the past two years uh
you converted your husband that's
awesome
i have pavlov dust to subconsciously
watch his videos every day during dinner
there's no escape
guys just watch anime instead it's okay
i release you from the pain of pewdiepie
i hear jiu jitsu kaizen is good no is
this what you refer to as floor gang
jesus what what what
what ah
well at least everything still works
you're fine
you're fine bro the game feels so anime
2019
2021 this is so freaking elevated
some things never change actually you
are watching an anime
clearly hey remember when people had
these but un-ironically
huh is there anything cool left [ __ ]
speed runs maybe i'll do speed runs
[Music]
just hit me all at once there's
everything's so [ __ ] lame dude
[Music]
that's a good meme hey up vote hell yeah
the fire nation base fridays and
pewdiepie
okay that's a twist i like that peeing
in the shower instead of the toilet just
once a day can save up to two thousand
liters of water per person every year
he was taking a [ __ ] in the shower i am
four parallel universes ahead of you
it was once all right get over it i'm
never sharing any more embarrassing
stories
i think we need to call it lawyer
because i don't like change
well someone said it at least you're
honest i
i prefer the why when it was a while not
foreign
it's never okay for men to give cpr to
an unconscious woman
resistation it's just a fancy way
hey fine you have chosen death
i had no other line i just wanted to
look cool for a sec i'm sorry
but here we go this is the problem with
with twitter everyone has an opinion now
it's the worst remember when people
didn't have a voice
i prefer it let's keep it that way
guys i'm amassing an actual army now
i think it's time we do something with
this audience instead of just [ __ ]
watching memes and the first thing we're
going to do is we're going to stop
daylight savings time we will use
peaceful violence
that's kind of cute villager shoots
firework after piers we need the right
they love me they love being trapped
forever i can't believe it
their emotions were there all along
they're loved uh
i should finish every achievement on my
hardcore yeah it just seems lame dude
i i just want a fire nation automatic
redstone farm
this system storage infinite uh
oh [ __ ] i got shout out
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh foods needs a new name for the y i
will make an abbreviation of a funny sex
word that would be hilarious
that will get him i'm glad you guys
still have some self
sense of self awareness thank you this
warms my heart
youtube hey burrito man is back with me
and me yay
it's so funny what's up it's me
hey i have my house backwards and it's
time to [ __ ] party
it's weird seeing me with his beard no
i'm markiplier guys
michael here oh
[Music]
okay no nah let's stop it
stop it stop it for real stop it
[Laughter]
it's at the beginning of minecraft
there's no watercolor don't
go we need dj psnap funky let's go we
have an automatic sorting system to
protect
oh man yeah oh
okay all right a little looter than i
expected but i like it
does it have to be me couldn't you just
made it like a cute
all right
this makes me laugh really ah
no no no it's time for me to create a
tick tock
follow me on tick tock and we will take
over i know actually i can't be bothered
i i'm and not even for a meme i can't do
it like no
changed my mind i can
i couldn't even finish that sense before
i stop myself
hey nick strongman was that his name i
forgot
please why don't you just do this i
don't get it
nick bess that was it i can't do one
push-up also appears
well apparently you have to keep your
legs really far apart
okay that's kind of funny we should call
it smush
bro last person i collaborated with
literally quits as he was great maybe
i'm quitting you
what the hell okay that's it for this
week's
friday's repair episode what episode
are we on i don't know this must be one
of the longest running shows on youtube
at this point
holy sh guys thanks for watching
remember to strike that subscribe button
and harm arm
and harm that like button and i see you
guys tomorrow
bye bye